[Music]
welcome to the solar system construction
zone
today you'll be using our cosmic sandbox
to build a brand new planet
what would you need to create a rocky
planet like earth
where should this planet be located to
be habitable
and how would this affect the rest of
our solar system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could create a new planet
during the formation of our solar system
billions of years ago
a giant disk of gas and dust circled our
young star
hydrogen helium and many other elements
swirled
eventually gravity lumped these
particles together
to form planetesimals
this was the first step on their journey
to becoming planets
eventually they grew into protoplanets
rocky planets composed of elements with
high melting points developed in the hot
inner solar system
and in the outer solar system icy gas
giants formed
this process occurred over many millions
of years so
what would happen if you fast-tracked
this planetary construction
would you be setting up our own planet
for destruction
now before you begin making your own
planet you might want to get some
otherworldly inspiration with magellan
tv
i recommend starting with undiscovered
worlds to see what exotic alien planets
exist out there magellan tv is a
documentary streaming service with the
richest science content on this planet
and they don't just cover space from
nature to technology they add hours of
new content every week in hd and 4k
with magellan tv you never run out of
something to watch and you can enjoy
their documentaries anytime anywhere on
your tv
laptop or even on your smartphone
start your free trial today so you can
watch undiscovered worlds and the rest
of magellan tv's science collection
claim your special offer at tri dot
magellan tv dot com slash what if that's
try.magellantv.com
what if
enjoy this out of this world experience
without leaving your home
and take notes you're about to build
your own world so what's it going to
look like
to get started on the construction
project of a lifetime you'd need certain
raw materials
to build a rocky planet like our own
you'd need four key elements that
account for 90
of the earth's crust
oxygen would be crucial as it's the most
abundant element on our planet
it makes up 47
of the mass of the crust and 21
of the atmosphere
the second necessary element would be
silicon
this accounts for another 28 of the
earth's crust
the other two essential elements would
be aluminum and iron
yeah with just those four you could
build your rock in space
but if you wanted to spice things up you
could add smaller traces of other
elements that make up the crust
like calcium
sodium and magnesium
but now the hard part would begin
since the developing days of our solar
system are long in the past
you'd need an alternative to gas and
dust swirling around a protostar
you'd need to follow a more manual plan
in the end this would be a blessing if
we had a new star developing in our
solar system it would cause serious
gravitational disturbances
not to mention that temperatures as high
as 1700 degrees would scorch everything
so where would you get all the materials
well you could start by mining the
asteroid belt located between mars and
jupiter
but this would be a very small start
here you'd accumulate only four percent
of the mass of the moon
if you ventured way out beyond pluto
you'd be able to accumulate
significantly more material in the oort
cloud
you'd now have a mass of material equal
to about five earths from the icy comet
like objects out there
the next step would be to pick the
location for your shiny new planet
if you wanted to have conditions for
life it would be necessary to place it
within the habitable zone
this means the planet would need to
orbit our sun at a distance of 0.9 to
1.2 astronomical units
so it would be in our planetary neck of
the woods
somewhere between venus and us or us and
mars this proximity would have some
significant repercussions on earth
while our planet is primarily impacted
by the gravitational pull of the sun
compared to the pull of other planets
this new world would cause some
disruptions
it could shift our orbit and even cause
tsunamis or devastating earthquakes
so it would be wise to make a planet
smaller than earth
but just how small it would need to be
to avoid catastrophe would still be a
gamble
okay finally it's time to get building
and in this case
that would require manually slamming all
your collected objects into each other
until they fuse
sounds easy right
not so fast the other major challenge
for you would be time
planets take at least 10 million years
to form naturally
plus you'd have to wait for delivery of
all that material from the oort cloud
based on the expected 300 years it will
take nasa's voyager 1 spacecraft to
reach this place
you could expect a round-trip delivery
window of at least 600 years
so much for an easy job
maybe it would be better not to disrupt
billions of years of the delicate
balance of our solar system
who knows what kind of planetary
disruptions a new planet would come with
i mean you'd hate to see jupiter and
saturn suddenly collide
or would you
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]